direction à présent bagnolet en seine
saint denis là bas comme dans d'autres
villes de la région parisienne la crise
sanitaire aura fortement impacté
certaines familles déjà en situation
précaire conséquence depuis fin avril 21
une famille locataire d'un immeuble du
parc privé ont suspendu le paiement de
leur loyer en cause une hausse des
charges durant le confinement reportage
signé rhône au parquet charles beaudry
et jordi demoury revenu 0 loyer 0
c'est le slogan d'une des banderoles
accrochées à la façade d'un immeuble à
bagnolet en seine-saint-denis depuis la
fin du mois d'avril les habitants de
cette résidence privée et tire la
sonnette d'alarmé avec le confinement
ils sont nombreux à connaître des
difficultés financières
dans ce contexte de chômage partiel et
de baisse de revenus l'augmentation des
charges durant le confinement a fait
bondir les locataires on a donc envoyé
un courrier fin avril pour du coup à
alerter sur cette situation on a créé un
comité
un comité des locataires donc avec avec
le soutien de droit au logement
l'association dal pour justement un peu
faire face à cette situation et donc on
a envoyé un courrier pour expliquer un
petit peu l'ensemble des d une chose
qu'on avait identifiées qui nous
paraissaient problématique à la fois
donc effectivement le l'idée d'un
moratoire sur les loyers mais aussi tous
les dysfonctionnements
et donc voilà on a envoyé sa 4 fin avril
on a à proposer en fait aux bailleurs de
venir nous rencontrer
pour en discuter la réponse qui nous a
été faite c'était que effectivement avec
les règles de confinement c'était
compliqué et donc nous on fait un
courrier de retour reprenant point par
point et voilà mais on espère toujours
pouvoir les rencontrer rapidement pour
pouvoir évoquer cette situation
outre les loyers les charges les
habitants de l'immeuble ont voulu aussi
attiré l'attention sur les
détériorations dans certains
appartements fuite d'eau mauvaise
isolation problèmes de ventilation
les griefs sont nombreux là donc il ya
deux séries de studio un rez-de-chaussée
ou en rez-de-chaussée bas donc tout ce
débat très clairement ils sont enterrés
sont les fenêtres là donc j'ai toute une
histoire de vmc de chaudières ils n'ont
ni le chauffage ni la vmc ni aucune
enfin je veux dire il n'ya pas
d'isolation rien du tout donc ils
prennent toutes les méditer donc l'hiver
même si on n'a pas des hivers sibériens
franchement le quand il fait très humide
et c'est terrible depuis la lettre
envoyée aux bailleurs quelques travaux
ont été effectués mais la situation de
cet immeuble n'est qu'un exemple parmi
tant d'autres en france
l'état a injecté 110 milliards d'euros
dans l'économie
illarine a mis sur le logement c'est
atterrant c'est à dire que derrière on
risque d'avoir à partir de l'année
prochaine
c'est une bombe sociale qui s'annonce
avec des dizaines de milliers
d'expulsions supplémentaire des gens qui
vont se retrouver à la rue on risque de
se retrouver dans la situation qu'on a
connue aux états unis ou en espagne
après la crise des subprimes en 2009 où
c'est des millions de ménages compte est
foutu dehors
est ce que c'est ça qu'on veut en france
non ça je pense que on doit mettre en
place ses filets de sécurité d'une part
mettre en place un fonds d aide aux
impayés de loyers conséquents de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
voire un ou deux milliards d'euros
il faut suspendre les sanctions pour
l'encontre des locataires qui ont des
difficultés de paiement
il faut suspendre l'expulsion effective
et jusqu'à l'année prochaine
après on verra et enfin il faut agir
mener une politique efficace de lutte
contre le logement cher c'est-à-dire
encadrer les loyers plus taxés durement
les profits spéculatifs
le confinement à augmenter la précarité
de locataires touchés par la crise du
coronavirus un contexte difficile qui
s'ajoute à la tensions spéculatives aux
abords des gares du grand paris qui
semble donc se poursuivre